salut à tous aujourd'hui pour fait qu'il
fasse beau pour pouvoir se mettre en
extérieur pour pouvoir parler d'une
question qui m'a été posée une question
qui m'a été posée par par jason andré ça
lui jason salut je voudrais savoir comme
tu dis dans une de tes vidéos que tu es
un grand fan d'apple
est-ce que l'apple watch cette notre là
c'est vraiment quelque chose à part
donner l'heure en voilà alors ça c'est
une excellente question alors c'est sûr
que l'apple watch elle sert à plein de
choses mises à part donner l'heure
est-ce qu'elles servent vraiment à autre
chose qu'à être un complément de ça et
c'est ça la vraie question réalité parce
que l'apple white si tu veux j'utilise
maintenant plein de cas différents le
tout premier cas c'est pour passer des
coups de fil ça c'est génial tu leur
poignet est en train de conduire
théo bureau tu es en train de bosser a
pas envie de prendre ton téléphone tu le
30 mai en main libre tu décroches
alors effectivement s'il ya du monde
autour de toi et que tu peux passer
rapidement la merde mais sinon tu
décroches tu parle directement dans le
mieux c'est quand tu conduis tuque la
législation t'empêche d'avoir un kit
mains libres d'avoir des oreillettes
tu peux dire qu'on va avoir un bluetooth
dans la bagnole pour l'instant on dit
rien sur la pelouse h
à ma connaissance donc en tout cas j'ai
l'apple watch je décroche
chez les mains sur le volant je conduis
le son est très bon on m'entend et ça
c'est génial le deuxième point qui est
vraiment pas que tu appelles oil ce sont
les sms c'est à dire que tu vas recevoir
directement ton sms sur ta montre alors
effectivement t'as pas de clavier tu vas
pas taper ça c'est impossible par contre
une dictée vocale qui est vraiment top
tu vas prendre le temps tu va dicter tu
vas bien prononcé bien articuler prend
le temps de pas trop manger tes mots et
tu aura vraiment une qualité d'envoi qui
est génial donc ça je te recommande donc
ça c'est vraiment un facilitateur de vie
si tu peux pas prendre ton téléphone ne
peut pas décrocher la montre la paix
watch pour ça c'est vraiment très
pratique sur les fonctions de base alors
elles donnent leurs unes des fonctions à
ce qui marche aussi super bien ensuite
il ya plein d'autres points sont
vraiment diax apple watch je pense
notamment aux notifications c'est à dire
que moi qui suis par exemple un grand
consommateur médias toutes les
notifications de tout ce que tu veux
comme journaux
tu les as directement tu peut les
consulter ce qui fait que même si tu
n'as pas ton téléphone sous la main tu
es en permanence connectés et ça c'est
bien voilà mais ça effectivement pour
l'instant on est sur une fonctionnalité
que tu as aussi là dessus ça simplifie
aussi la vie par rapport à pas mal de
petites applications ton agenda
tu as directement t rappelle moi j'ai
une application qui sert à
à gérer une liste de courses qui
s'appelle bring alors brink's et le top
parce que ça me permet si tu veux dans
mon téléphone lorsque je suis chez moi
je note tout les produits qu'il faut
pour manier de course et lorsque je suis
en magasin je suis dessus je clique
dessus une fox 2000 dans mon caddie ça
me wade coche et je veux vraiment ce qui
me reste donc voilà ça fait partie des
petits facilitateur c'est évident
d'avoir le téléphone à la main mais
effectivement c'est pas en ça que cet
appel watch et révolutionnaire ce qui
est vraiment bien avec l'apple watch si
tu veux c'est tout ce qui est je dirais
sport c'est à dire que derrière
effectivement ici ça va te mesurer par
exemple ton rythme cardiaque lorsque tu
fais du sport qui sera exactement
combien de plus à sion par minute tu as
ou est ce que tu as dans ton effort tu
peux te mettre des objectifs tu peux
avoir une progression des forces si tu
es vraiment dans une je dirais dans une
dynamique sportive ou une dynamique où
tu peux faire de plus en plus d'efforts
ça c'est un super assistants et je
dirais qu'à mon sens c'est la fonction
première de cette montre c'est vraiment
là dessus qu'elle se démarque par
rapport à un iphone parce que au final
entre ça et ça il n'y a pas énormément
de différence tu peux envoyer des
messages à plein d'un prix de la côte et
de l'autre la tuque - faire les choses
avec tes applis ou sinon effectivement
bas il faut switch est là dessus mais
voilà je dirais que ça fait partie d'un
écosystème ça fait partie de
l'écosystème apple en complément avec
effectivement un iphone un ipad tu à
l'appel watch qui marche très bien et
qui à mon sens c'est vraiment une super
montre alors après il ya toujours des
petits plus saintes un gps sur la série
ce2 d'un gps
elle peut te repérer savoir où tu te
dire où sont par exemple les restaurants
à proximité les bars dans une ville que
tu connais pas voilà c'est un peu un
assistant personnel série est très très
très au point là dessus donc on est
vraiment voilà sur sur un bel objet
personnellement je pourrais m'en passer
je suis très heureux de l'avoir parce
qu'elle me tarde vraiment au quotidien
j'ai par exemple toutes les
notifications sur ma chaîne youtube
je sais exactement quels sont les
derniers commentaires je peux les voir
je peux vraiment interagir et ça me
permet de dire et d'être encore plus
connectés voir un petit peu trop
connectés maintenant le côté un petit
peu négatif de cette monde si tu veux
pas résidé dans le fait que tu es limité
je prends par exemple le développement
de facebook de facebook messenger tu
peux voir compte envoyer un message peut
voir une notification tu peux pas y
répond quand tu peux pas les lire
directement dessus il faut aller sur ton
smartphone séance a effectivement que
tuer rapidement frustré après 7,1
facebook effectivement de développer
davantage
mais sur le principe sinon ça reste
quand même très
très bon outil donc voilà j'espère avoir
répondu à des questions si tu en as
d'autres tu l'aimés en commentaire j'y
répondrai avec le plus grand plaisir
n'hésite pas à ta bonne et regarde aussi
cette vidéo qui est très sympa et puis
je te dis à très vite
ciao